[Musik]
ja
wird frank walter steinmeier
bundespräsident eine frage die die
menschen elektrisiert und mindestens so
offen ist rhi hat deutschland beim esc
eine chance wird bayern münchen meister
und ist bernd höcker ein nazi
[Musik]
herr glaser hallo wir wollen ja alle
relevanten kandidaten vorstellen sie
sind freunde von mit von derartig also
gut dann schönen tag mit ihr natürlich
nie ich bin natürlich hier um die
bundesversammlung mitzugestalten und
freue mich dass ich dabei bin und so
ganz spannend ist es ja nicht weil wir
alle davon ausgehen dass frank walter
steinmeier gewählt werden wird nicht
wahr und deswegen wird auch mal weniger
zu level 4 oder wahlkrimi in berlin
das hört heute richtig spannend es geht
um die frage wie viel stimmen bekommt
frank walter steinmeier
doch noch offen man weiß überhaupt nicht
wert wird ich ahne es wie an sie haben
eine ahnung wer könnte es werden haben
sie eine prognose
ich finde sehr lustig was sind sie
lustig er warum bin ich lustig weil ich
die sache ernst nehmen weil ich die
demokratie ernst nehme deshalb bin ich
wirklich wie als armutsforscher können
wir doch bestimmt sagen die arm ist eine
wahl bei der der gewinner feststeht naja
damit die wahl nicht ganz fest stellte
spät von vornherein hab ich ja
kandidiert wahlkrimi in berlin
nein weder krimi noch ist das anders für
sonstige flockige bemerkungen wir
befinden uns jetzt in einem meer aus
guten gründen nur alle fünf jahre
stattfindenden wahlen zum
bundespräsidenten und warst du mal das
ergebnis in ruhe weil es so vorhersehbar
ist oder nicht mehr flockig sein das war
mein style wenn so gerne flockig
glauben sie dass auf diese wahlen von
russland manipuliert werden heute ich
gehe eigentlich nicht davon aus weil es
sind 1060 menschen zusammengekommen die
ganz sicherlich nicht alle einen draht
nach moskau haben vielleicht einige aber
eher die minderheit
die wahlen sind für uns wichtig dass der
bus land zu blöde eigentlich nein die
wahl für mich unwichtig sondern wir
feiern hier heute ein fester demokratie
bei der der gewinner schon fest steht
richter alexander hold
der einzige richter der noch unsere user
ist als preisrichter kann ich mich zu
sagen wer vor ein feuchter weiß einfach
nur eine beleidigung für mehr wem
schadet irre spaß kandidatur mehr dem
amt des bundespräsidenten dem amtes
richter
da haben sie etwas grundsätzlich falsch
verstand das ist keine spaß kandidatur
ich habe angst ihr anliegen aber im
winter der typ von sat 1 oder ja
hätten sie geglaubt dass sie diesen tag
noch erleben würden pro jahr fehlte
lebenserwartung hätte ich mir zugetraut
dadurch verliert im raum zu sein mit
jogi löw veronica ferres und roland
kaiser ist mehr oder ja das ist auf
jeden fall ne aber wichtiger noch ist
also mit frank walter steinmeier als
privat zu bestreiten und wäre dies amt
machen hatte keine lust mehr politik das
ist ja politik bundespräsidenten politik
aber ich glaube der nicht mal das volk
will unbedingt wissen wer ihr neuer
präsident wird und laufen vor dem
reichstag ist noch mehr los als bei der
amtseinführung von donald trump
[Applaus]